let's go for a uh
five minute game
the uber
2200 blitz from from germany
got ourselves a sicilian of the
classical search
um wow i thought it was going to go for
the night earth
okay you want a dragon sir
you could have you can have your dragon
i'm not afraid
i am a little bit afraid but not that
afraid
asics usually when people play
kind of dragon dragadorf style and
dragon and knight of hybrid
they don't castle that early because
this a6b5
you know bishop b7 knight
knight d7 and so on all that
uh that whole setup is a little bit slow
and when you castle kingside usually
you're gonna get slaughtered pretty
quickly with the
g4 h4 and bishop g
h6 and so on and this is not
this is not even about the opponent
that you're you're playing like
the thing that makes the dragon sort of
a
difficult opening for for black to play
is that
everybody knows or at least everybody
who's played
e4 at some point in their life everybody
just knows how to attack you just you
just push on the
on the king side
and this makes the dragon a very
difficult opening to play as black
but a more difficult but but an easier
opening to
to play as white and you can see here
um he's never got going on the queen
side
and already he's getting he's getting
mated i think
pretty shortly and unless he he finds
some
some brilliant defense so it's really
it's really not an opening um that you
want to play
play by by hand because people know what
to do as
white and most of the time you're just
gonna
you're just gonna get slaughtered um
basically
okay um yeah
yeah sorry dude that was that was just a
bad um
bad opening choice i'm sure my my
opponent is
usually a lot better than than
this but you gotta
you just i i think you just can't play
play this way when you play the the
dragon